[Music]
anybody here buy any facebook stock did
you get any stock on facebook
one guy did you really or you just
you're just applauding to hear yourself
later at a bar on television that was me
well the facebook stock is uh not doing
well did you know that yeah today the
price of facebook shares fell even lower
in fact at one point this afternoon mark
zuckerberg went from being a billionaire
to being still a billionaire
rough day for him
you know mark zuckerberg got married a
couple of days ago yeah well at their
wedding mark zuckerberg's wife wore a
dress that cost nearly five thousand
dollars
yeah that is until the dress went public
now it's worth two thousand dollars
it's a trend
it's a trend is what i'm saying how did
you hear this only one month after the
secret service prostitute scandal in
colombia three dea agents are also being
accused of hiring hookers in colombia
yeah
so today the obama campaign released an
ad calling the president number one in
job creation in colombia
[Applause]
that's my hooker uh
well they're very they're very i ever
have to turn to that for to make a
living that's how i'm gonna walk down
the street
all right
now will you have a big hairdo or i
don't know why i'm doing that all right
i think that's hair yeah yeah yeah it's
a big hairdo yeah uh it's interesting in
mexico
a female politician is running campaign
ads that feature her topless
yeah
i just want to say if this is the way
things are headed i am really happy that
newt gingrich is out of the race
[Applause]
too much
that was too much right
yeah that was too much when i acted it
out right it's too much
i'm with you on that yeah it was it was
definitely not presidential no no
this is crazy a new report suggests that
christopher columbus may have secretly
been jewish
christopher columbus jewish
yeah what tipped historians off was
columbus's uh diary entry where he
described his journey to america as a
real schlep
boy gevault i think he said
[Laughter]
bagged salads bag salads across the
country have been recalled due to
contamination fears
yeah
luckily this is america so none of the
salads were touched
[Music]
god help us if something happens to our
doritos supply
[Laughter]
[Applause]
then we're screwed
any ultimate fighting champion fans here
okay
an ultimate fighting champion has been
banned after testing positive for
marijuana
yeah yeah people thought he might be
stoned when he entered the ring and said
what are we fighting for ultimately
[Applause]
it all
comes together in the end
that's the important thing
khloe kardashian is in the news khloe
kardashian is refusing to take a
paternity test to determine if she's
actually a kardashian
she's refusing yeah she said i think my
record of fame without talent speaks for
itself
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
the inventor of the tv remote control
has passed away
as per his wishes he'll be buried
between two couch cushions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
see we're all friends again